maize or corn
is one of the most widely grown grains
in the world and is a staple in many of
our diets
but what you might not know is that the
way that much of it is processed
has contributed to making millions of
people sick and killing
hundreds of thousands over the past 500
years i'm dr bill schindler
food archaeologist chef and director of
the eastern shore food lab at washington
college
our modern approach to food processing
which prioritizes convenience and profit
over safety and nutrition
has negatively impacted the nutritional
value of maize for our human bodies
however there is a process that will
transform maize into its most nutritious
and delicious form but that process has
yet to be adopted by most of the world
and that's what we're going to talk
about today
archaeological evidence suggests that
maize domestication may have started
thousands of years ago
in the balsas valley of mexico it comes
from a wild grass known as teosente
and these right here are grains from the
wild teosinte plant
now archaeologists are not even sure why
maize domestication even started in the
first place
was it for food was it for the alcohol
they could create out of it
was it for some utilitarian purpose or
was it for something else altogether
what we do know is that the genetic
mutations that have occurred have
transformed
wild teosentei grains into maize as we
know it today
for example early versions of maize had
kernels that were individually wrapped
just like this this required a
tremendous amount of time and labor to
harvest
so early farmers were able to
genetically modify maize
to produce a cob covered by one husk
like we know it today
these types of transformations increase
the volume of food
and decrease the amount of work
necessary to access that food
however maize is one of the most
difficult grains in the world
for our human digestive tracts to fully
break down and from which to derive the
maximum amount of nutrition it is very
high in cellulose
and insoluble fiber that our bodies
cannot break down and
some of the nutrients exist in forms
that our bodies just can't access
however early farmers discovered a
process known as nistomalization
which provided their bodies access to
that nutrition
originally this process involves
steeping kernels of maize
in a solution of water and wood ash but
over time wood ash was replaced with lye
and even pickling lime but the process
remains the same the mixture of a base
with water
creates an alkaline solution which
chemically and physically transforms the
maize
into its safest and most nourishing form
possible for our digestive tracts
mestamalization has many benefits for
instance it detoxifies grains
and neutralizes anti-nutrients such as
phytic acid
it raises the calcium content by up to
400 percent increases the protein
quality
improves the amino acid balance and
releases niacin
from niacin its natural form which is
bound up
and otherwise unavailable to our bodies
finally
it makes the grains easier to grind and
transforms the flavor
aroma and texture nastamalizing maize
produces niche tamale
and grinding this tamal produces a dough
known as masa
from masa a number of different
traditional foods can be made
such as tortillas tamales and even a
drink known as atole
when made properly using traditional
processing
these foods are incredibly nourishing
today
maize is in almost every processed food
and is a staple for people around the
world
however in modern food processing the
crucial nistomalization process
is almost always skipped over outside of
areas with ancient ties
to maize production in fact many food
producers
likely don't even know it's a
possibility when nistomization is
skipped
much of the maize's nutrition remains
locked up and inaccessible to our bodies
no matter how we cook it when we eat
maize like this we are literally passing
nutrients
from our food through our bodies and
into our waste
historically this widespread absence of
nichtomization and maize processing
has even led to more serious problems
across the globe there is a disease
called pellagra
caused by a deficiency of niacin in the
diet that produces symptoms
such as red scaly skin diarrhea
dementia and in advanced stages even
death
over the past several hundred years as
maize has spread around the world
this disease has followed in its wake
because maize is incredibly cheap and
filling
it regularly dominates diets often to
the exclusion of other food
and essential nutrients cultures that
become over-reliant on maize maize that
has not been nastamolized
do not have access to all the nutrition
that it contains
as a result millions of people around
the world ate massive quantities of
maize
became deficient in niacin and pellagra
ran rampant
just think about how crazy that is
people around the world are getting sick
and dying from a niacin deficiency while
eating large amounts of a food
that contains niacin while this might
not be a big concern for you in your
area
there are still places that rely heavily
on maze experiencing this problem in the
early 20th century
millions of americans got pellagra which
resulted in the deaths of hundreds of
thousands
when we realized what the problem
actually was instead of adopting the
practice of nistomalization we made the
decision
to artificially enrich foods with niacin
when we artificially enrich our food
we're addressing one symptom but we're
missing the much larger underlying
problem
yes it provides us with niacin but we
miss out on all the other benefits of
nistomalization
and just as importantly we miss out on
the opportunity to connect with a
traditional practice
that has such incredible cultural
significance
to meet the demand of an ever-increasing
population scientists are developing
things like new insecticides and genetic
modifications
to increase maize production but before
taking such drastic measures
i wonder if we shouldn't first do
everything that we can
to make the most of the maze that we're
already growing and harvesting
since maize is the most widely grown
grain in the world just think about the
impact
that nastamalizing every single kernel
of it
would have on our food supply there are
choices that you can make and things
that you can do to make a difference
make a statement with your paycheck and
support small tortillas
and local food producers who are doing
everything possible to produce
safe nourishing food remember tortillas
contain
one ingredient nishtamali's maize refuse
to purchase tortillas
that contain dozens of ingredients or
better yet
nastamalyze maize and make tortillas
from scratch in your own kitchen
for millions of years our ancestors
developed technologies and approaches to
food
to make it safe nutrient dense and
bioavailable but most modern food
processing does the exact opposite
today for the first time in the history
of the world
we can create obesity and malnutrition
in the same individual
that means the processed food that we're
eating is so
free of nutrients that we can eat
massive quantities of it
and still be malnourished this isn't
just happening with maize
it's happening in different ways
throughout our food system
this is a problem we don't need new food
innovations to solve
early maize farmers solved this problem
thousands of years ago
what we need to do is look to the past
and incorporate those traditional
practices
into our modern food system